what would you tell a 20 year old
filmmaker on the realities of making a
living as a filmmaker it's funny because
they just start a podcast with the same
idea which is the phrase here's my
advice not that you'll take it listen to
the people giving you advice first off
because you think that they're coming
from what they're gonna tell you if it's
honest advice is harsh it's not going to
be easy it's gonna require a lot more
money and patience and heartache and you
think you can bear and you're gonna say
they just sound jaded because they've
been around a long time there must be a
faster cheaper easier way to get this
done and then you'll fumble in the dark
for a long time to eventually turn
around and say oh that advice they gave
me I should have taken it so listen to
your elders you know you hit a certain
point where you started saying that to
people as they oh it's exactly what my
parents said to me but yeah the best
thing is just take take advice take the
time to learn don't ever think that
you're above something like if you want
to be a director great go grip on some
people's films and understand and watch
other directors work understand how
important every role and that said is so
that you never talk down or take it and
take anyone for granted that's on the
set and just keep making stuff like even
if you're even if you're not proud of
this short you may put it up online
anyways it's part of learning to take
criticism it's part of learning to fail
yeah just keep making stuff and
understand that it's it's it's it's the
longest relationship you'll ever have
because you will fall in and out of love
with it along the way but it doesn't
mean you should ever give up or not give
it a second chance or not find a way to
you know make amends kiss and make up
with you yourself and your creative
dreams and don't ever think that a major
setback means it's over because you're
gonna have a lot of them and most of us
do not all of us are lucky to get
plucked in a film school in our first
film and have a star track record right
you two there you know a lifetime
achievement or it's at the end of their
career it's it's a it's a lot of a lot
of misery it's like I always say it's 99
setbacks for every one thing that
so when that hunter thing works out it
has to fill you with so much excitement
and joy and courage and wanting to let
go and make the next thing that the next
that it will it will shield you from the
next 99 disappointments so that when you
get the next one you got to do the same
things that's that's the reality of it
it's gonna it's gonna sting for a long
time but you got to just enjoy what
you're doing along the way and learn to
not be end career focused because you
never know how it's going to come about
but if you try to fixate on it has to be
this this and this rarely life is that
so you have to be able to say it's gonna
be this but I might have to take this
sideways trip it look like well as
Indiana Jones maps at the beginning area
James Bond to go from country to country
they want to go from here to here
sometimes that means Salah is going to
take them all over here to get back to
that arc
you